it had to be done
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles the 2014
edition is directed by Michael Bay I'm
sorry I mean Jonathan Lyte vestment it
stars Megan Fox's April O'Neill who
stumbles across four Turtles who are
ninjas who live in the sewers love pizza
and are trained by a rat named splinter
and the evil shredder and his Foot Clan
are taking over the city and they must
stop them now if you grew up in the 90s
at all you've heard of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles you probably played
some of the games you probably watch the
original films you probably have
merchandise you probably saw the
cartoons you probably watched some of
the newer cartoons and you were probably
one of the people who angrily typed on
various forms that oh my gosh they're
raping my childhood because look it's
Michael Bay and he's trying to get into
a Michael Bay fest and I understand how
you may feel that way but here's my
opinion on the whole thing I've never
really thought that any of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movies were really
all that great I think it's really just
a lot of nostalgia the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles films were never trying to
be oscar-worthy movies they were never
really going for this amazing experience
they are turtles who live in a sewer
trained by a rat and they love pizza you
can't really take that too seriously
unless you grew up with those films
they're probably not going to be all
that amazing to you because they're
really just a slice of nostalgia from
your childhood so when I was watching
this movie I wasn't really that
surprised by the fact that it's it's not
really that good but I recognize that
more than likely kids who see this movie
will love it and if they make a reboot
20 years from now those kids who saw
this movie in 2014 are gonna say they're
raping my childhood oh my gosh kids who
grew up with this movie will go back and
watch the one from the 90s and think it
looks like crap they're gonna think it
looks like just a bunch of guys in
rubber shoes because that's what it was
I don't really think the director of
this movie directed as much of it as he
thinks he did because this really feels
like a Michael Bay movie the
storytelling is so terrible there's
literally a scene in which William
Fichtner brings April O'Neil into his
room he has an entire map laid out on
the wall which I'm going to refer to as
the exposition room he
has a map on his wall with artistic
drawings in which he can explain the
entire history of his life and so much
of the story time you need to understand
this film is done through flashbacks or
someone overhearing a conversation it's
all very lazy
just like with Michael Bay whenever
there is an action scene that does not
involve 100% digital effects he just
shakes the camera around over and over
again but when you have the turtles
doing their ninja moves and you have
Splinter and shredder fighting it's very
fluid it's very vivid and that's because
it's an entirely digitally created shot
so there's a lot of skill there in
regards to the computer technicians who
created that scene but ask for direction
you can't really get into it because it
feels like you're watching a cartoon
it's really a movie that's made for
younger kids and I think they'll enjoy
because there's a really cool action
scene in this film with an avalanche
scene that I thought was done really
well some of the action is fun and
exciting some of the turtles tell some
funny jokes but for the most part it's
really just a Michael Bay movie with
Megan Fox running around screaming a
damsel in distress and a terrible
terrible comedic side character in Will
Arnett who is absolutely awful
and completely miscast in this film the
film tries to make you care about
certain emotional beats that you just
don't care about there's an endless
amount of product placement of course
including a absolutely gratuitous shot
in which the turtles use their shells to
become the bikini on a Victoria Secret
billboard ad to cover the girls boobs
thanks Michael Bay one other thing this
movie has literally the exact same
ending as the amazing spider-man if
you've seen that film I'm not gonna
spoil it for you since it's the ending
but just watch it every single thing
that happens in that ending is exactly
what happens at the end of the Amazing
Spiderman I'll put it this way if you
enjoyed the Transformers films quite a
bit you'll probably really like this
movie if you are looking for even a
shred of clever filmmaking that doesn't
involve a whole bunch of special effects
thrown in your face you're not really
going to have a lot of fun with this
movie I'm gonna give Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles a D+ but in all honesty I
don't think this film degrades into the
other films that came before because a
lot of them really weren't that great to
begin with and it's just kind of more
the same just with a lot of CGI thrown
in guys if you do see this movie let me
know what you think below and thank you
so much for watching and as always if
you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck Minh heist also
I wanted to really quick let you guys
know that the really awesome people at
audible.com have kept me on as an
advertiser for them for the rest of this
year that's been a big help to me and I
received a lot of messages from you guys
thanking me for all the free audio books
and that is so awesome I'm really glad
you guys are benefiting from that if you
go to audible.com slash Chris you can
download a free audio book of your own
choice I downloaded a lot of Stephen
King's books because he's one of my
favorite authors there's a lot of really
cool stuff on there and I hope you guys
do check that out you can download any
audiobook you want narrated by many
celebrities straight to your phone your
tablet your PC your iPod whatever you
want to use to listen to these things
you can it's awesome check out
audible.com slash Chris thanks so much
to audible for continuing to support my
videos and thank you so much to you guys
who have downloaded stuff from them you
guys Rock